hashtag free britney could be coming
true that's because her dad jamie spears
is willing to permanently step down as
her conservator this news confirmed to
e.t by brittany's attorney this is just
a groundbreaking day now britney's
father agreed to the removal even if he
doesn't think it's a good idea according
to tmz court documents filed by jamie
say in part there are in fact no actual
grounds for suspending or removing mr
spears as the conservator of the estate
nevertheless even as mr spears is the
unremitting target of unjustified
attacks he does not believe that a
public battle with his daughter over his
continuing service as her conservator
would be in her best interest in
addition jamie stated that he'll work
with brittany's new attorney so there's
a quote orderly transition to a new
conservator jamie also says in the court
docks that he will
always be miss spears's father he will
always love her unconditionally and he
will always look out for her best
interests
brittany's attorney matthew rosengart
said in a statement we are pleased that
mr spears and his lawyer have today
conceded in a filing that he must be
removed we are disappointed however by
their ongoing shameful and reprehensible
attacks on ms fears and others
rosengart goes on to say that britney's
legal team isn't finished and that they
plan on continuing a quote vigorous
investigation which will dig into
jamie's conduct over the past 13 years
that fits with what brittany herself
advocated for during her bombshell
testimony in a hearing earlier this year
in which she compared life and her
conservatorship to sex trafficking and
said her dad as well as others involved
should be in jail last month rosengart
spoke to the press about their efforts
leading up to thursday's shocking update
less than two weeks ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears
it is now a matter of public record
and i announced to judge penny this
afternoon
that we have done so
in less than two weeks
we look forward to litigating the matter
in court
[Music]